Now as a reminder, polarization occurs when we bring a charged object
next to an uncharged conductor and allow the charges to separate
because the negatives are charged to the positive and the positives are repelled.
Now, I want to do something a little different, something that we haven't done before.
I want you to really think creatively here and tell me how can we use this idea of polarization
to create a charged object or maybe to create two charged objects?
You can start to see here that it looks like there should be a way
to create something that's charged here.
Maybe one, maybe two objects that are charged but I leave it up to you to enter into this box
what you think would be the best way to create charged objects using this polarization idea.
If you think you have a particularly clever method, you should go to the form and share it there.
Since I'm so confident that you can tell me this answer on your own,
I'm not going to tell you at all but if the anticipation is just killing you
and you need to know if your method is right, which I bet it is,
you can go ahead and look up charging by induction.
Go ahead and enter your answer here.
Don't worry, you'll be marked correct regardless of what you put
but I hope put some time to this and I'll be going over and looking for some clever ways
to charge an object using this idea of polarization.